[Music]
have you ever been in love
no one's ever offered I didn't see you
before I don't have to print it for what
that story that's written all over your
face
[Music]
I'll grab breakfast I just met you
[Music]
do you make time for one another in what
way do you have date night yeah what do
you do this this is love at its absolute
best and it's beautiful sometimes I
can't bring a baby into the world with a
man that I don't love don't do it
because you're scared you must own your
actions in life my penis that's great
there's a sex injury I mean it's not a
weird one hey why are you still talking
wrong I don't know love is trust and you
broke it I don't love him
it's totally my dad you're gonna smell
you smelled him oh your stay in New York
she's thing with us okay have you guys
discussed that we're discussing right
now it's a live discussion I'm so glad
you've told me it explains so much
surely there is someone out there it
will take me for who I am
good bad simple story of love
[Music]
SUIM ah
[Music]